want to talk to a bill Orem he writes
for the athletic he covers the Lakers
and he used to work in Salt Lake City
and I want to ask him about that with
what happened with Russell Westbrook not
that he can speak on behalf of this fan
last night who had the run-in with
Russell Westbrook in fact could we play
a little bit of this Seaton before we
get to a bill with Russell how about we
we play the incident with Russell
Westbrook with his fan last night in
Salt Lake City
[Music]
[Music]
all right it was ugly last night now the
camera is trained on Russell Westbrook
he's at the end of the bench there is
security there I don't know if it's team
security I don't know if they're
employed by Oklahoma City if it's just
somebody who works at Sault you know in
Salt Lake at the arena but an ugly
incident the fan gave his side of this
and said he said to Russ a you better
ice your knees
Russell Westbrook said no he told me to
get down on my knees whether that was a
sexual reference or a racial reference
in Russell Westbrook's mind he went off
both sides look bad obviously you know
with this fan if you're engaging with
him and you got what you wanted and he's
since done interviews and then people
have sort of checked his background to
see who he is and as he somebody who
does this incites this you know is there
something else on his social media that
might give a little indication of what
role he played there but Russell
Westbrook you can't you knows he can't
and easy for me to say okay you can't do
that but it's a bad look for him he has
everything to lose here not this fan who
got 15 minutes of fame if you want to
call it that but it was an ugly incident
well we've seen this before in Salt Lake
City we've seen this with Utah Jazz fans
before Russell Westbrook has had a
run-in before with fans there let's
bring in a bill worm who covers the
Lakers for the athletic formerly covered
the Jazz for the Salt Lake Tribune what
do you make of this bill last night Dan
I you know it was interesting because it
does seem like we keep hearing about
these incidents but jazz fans
specifically with Russell Westbrook and
then other players come out of the
woodwork and say oh yeah the fans in
Salt Lake are the worst and I support
Russell I think you're right there's
this responsibility all around here and
the thing that I guess I keep coming
back to is I don't think you can make
this about one about this particular fan
base being terrible or worse like it
being a reflection of the city or
culture of Utah at large and I think a
lot of people trying to try to jump on
that whether it's about Mormon culture
about you know whatever whatever part of
Utah people want to latch on to you know
I I think jazz fans are great
but no doubt there are jerks in that
crowd like anywhere else you know one
thing about Salt Lake City is those fans
are right on top of the court in a way
they aren't anywhere else in the league
you watch those games there are not
they're not the lanes behind the basket
it is it is a tight tight squeeze that
arena and and whether that gives fans a
sense of license to be more involved in
the game or if it just makes players
more aware of fans being there but
ultimately the onus the onus for this
falls on the player who is being paid I
think you know millions of dollars to be
on the floor and and and and putting on
a you know show essentially in that
environment which is not to say that
Russell Westbrook should have to
tolerate verbal abuse like he is
describing from last night there has to
be a mechanism in place where he can
point into the crowd and a security
guard gets that fan out of there if
they're really that abuse really rises
to that level but for us with Westbrook
to stand there and and rate a fan in
that manner ultimately reflects way
worse on him and and you know probably I
wouldn't say the Thunder but certainly
on Russell Westbrook and his
relationship with with fans than it does
on on one fan who perhaps got out of
hand a game what do you think the
commissioners response is going to be
well that's a good question I mean I I
think Russell Westbrook cast that has to
see something here just for just just
for the way he handled it and for the
profanity and for the and for the threat
I mean the ultimately that was a that
was a threat of physical violence
against a fan of the game and that and
that simply can't happen now do I think
that the NBA will may be out there up
there responds to poor fan behavior I
mean they've started putting any of
these cards at games that are basically
a fan code of conduct in the area around
around the court and that obviously is
not working and this is a cleared I'm
gonna that's not going that's not going
to get anything done right so if there's
a zero tolerance tolerance policy to be
had or something like that where a
player
feels like they do have recourse I think
that would be certain something
absolutely worth looking at but frankly
I think in any NBA arena if a plan is is
verbally abusing players to that degree
I've seen players I've seen I've seen
fans you know ejected out of games for
being for being too vulgar so I mean
that's not something that is completely
without precedent yeah and but you can't
be threatening a guy's wife I don't care
what he says and and I'm guessing that
he knew that he was on camera somebody
was videotaping this and I know you get
caught up in the moment you want to you
want to you know go after somebody you
just can't he has more to lose than this
fan who got his 15 minutes of fame I
want to bring up the Luke Waltons last
days question mark your most recent
column how the Lakers strayed from their
values and are now set to betray their
coach we sort of saw this when coming a
little while ago but is is it over
before it's over with Luke Walton has he
done I mean that's that's the assumption
that everyone I've spoken to around the
league and with the Lakers seems to have
you know there are people who told me
they think there's chance Luke could
survive this it would it would take it
was taking intervention by Genie bus and
it would take you know a pretty complete
overhaul of I think the coaching staff
but at this point I think what has
happened is that the Lakers the Lakers
said they supported Luke Lee so they
were going to give him the kind of
support you would need to succeed even
with LeBron James in town I think
ultimately whenever he needed that
support you know whether it was needing
somebody to back him up when the VAR
ball swept in or when you know rich Paul
was kind of working behind the scenes so
it kind of poison the well with Luke I
don't think that I don't think that Luke
Walton had that support and then
ultimately eroded his his relationship
with his locker room and ultimately find
him looking for work this summer and I
think that's where the shame in this
whole thing is because the Lakers made
promises back in 2016
about what kind of organization they
wanted to be after cycling through four
coaches and six seasons and uni buss
said the most important thing with
stability on the bench and identifying a
style of play and building
culture and those are all things that
Luke Walton brought and I think you can
you can certainly you can certainly take
issue with some of his tactical acumen
and there are always going to be you
know there's always going to be an
expectation that when a team falls apart
to the degree the Lakers have that you
just solved it by firing the coach I
just think that the Lakers have not
really expect by Luke in the way they
said they would when he's actually for
the most part delivered on the things
that he said he would bring to the table
in terms of elevating the offense
developing the young guys and
instituting a culture it just seems like
things that fall apart more quickly here
their make than they probably should
have whose not back there next year now
we can talk about Luke Walton not being
back there yeah player you know even
with with Ingram and that situation you
can't trade him and then you got Lonzo
ball you got Kyle Kuzma Josh Hart who's
back who's not well I think I think you
hit the nail on the head with Ingram
simply because I don't I don't think
there you know I won I think they liked
him and the player and would like to
keep him so there's that but to with his
health I don't see how any other team
could could feel comfortable trading for
him which is just really unfortunate
because he the players whose value was
skyrocketing before before obviously but
like the blood clot was delivered in his
in his arm he's due for that rookie
extension in October I don't think the
Lakers can make can give him that so
really I mean that everything is going
to be depending on how quickly he can
get it back on the floor what his health
is and then and then how how this next
season plays out for him and how he go
is going into the next summer and
frankly a year beyond that but but for
now I think he's definitely back
everyone else I think it's it's up in
the air I mean long football is an
injury prone second-year point guard who
is going to have played some 50 games
the second year after playing 52 games
as a rookie that is not a good that is
not a good look I don't know how much
other teams are willing to give up for a
point guard who you don't think can play
50 games Josh Hart has not been able to
knock down threes and has had his own
injury issues but one guy who I think
had some trade values Kyle Kuzma and
he's the guy who's probably played the
best next to look
all year the problem is I mean nobody's
gonna think this is a good idea just
roll it back with LeBron and these young
guys maybe a smattering of you know new
free agents you know new veterans on
one-year deals I mean that just simply
didn't work so I would fully expect that
the Lakers you know get busy trying to
trying to find combinations of those
young guys that can met them some
veterans on the tolerable deals that
will start to flush you know flush out a
roster around LeBron because I think I
think there was the ultimate results of
this season they're 30 and 36 that
they're probably I mean I know they won
35 games last year and Luke Waltons
second year at the helm and I don't
think they're gonna get there this year
there's 16 games less they go 5 and 11
I'll be surprised
so that would so I mean they're going to
take a pretty gnarly step back this year
and that and I think that that will give
Magic Johnson and Rob the link assuming
assuming they're both still here a
license to really tear this thing down
and and take a whole new approach
because it is not it has not worked bill
good to talk to you again as always
thanks for joining us thank you Dan
that's a bill arm he covers the Lakers
for the athletic used to work in Salt
Lake at the Salt Lake Tribune covering
the Utah Jazz for more Dan Patrick show
to the audience Channel 239 on DirecTV
or download the Dan Patrick show at
[Music]